modcloth is my first company that i
started my boyfriend at the time who's
now my husband and I we started together
back in 2002 I was 17 at the time
modcloth was really really small too
beginning I mean there were months would
go by where we just had a handful of
orders I think the biggest challenge
being a student was obviously like
balancing my time because you know I was
investing a lot in getting a great
education I did an independent study
course with Professor RF culbertson in
the Entrepreneurship department and so I
was able to you know for credit work on
my business and have a mentor and kind
of sit down and talk about plans for the
business and sort of challenges that I
was facing I remember sitting there and
professor culbertson saying like looking
at the website traffic and I think at
that time we were getting something like
seventy thousand unique visits a month
you know him sitting there and saying
like hey like if you had a store in
downtown Pittsburgh you probably
wouldn't have 70,000 unique people
walking in through your doors every day
like this is maybe something that's
that's special and that's that you can
actually pursue getting able to work on
the business while I was an
undergraduate at CMU really gave me the
confidence to test new things out to
kind of like see what worked learning
about my customer learning about my
business model and also having that
mentorship as part of the undergraduate
program as well
you